et la belle et la bête et échanges de
regards et comme d'hab
vas-y mai
mais frêche injuste de m'asseoir je vais
pas me veut maintenant relève toi c'est
pas ça me dit tu me conseilles un peu
plus précis on regarde prends ton
portefeuille
voilà va la voir et tu lâches un truc du
genre excuse moi c'est pas tant ce
portefeuille jeunes se trouvaient par
terre
ok elle a normalement on va dire non
avec quoi dire pour aborder mais fait
mais marius fais moi confiance s'arrêta
de faire ça donc c'est pas insurmontable
c'est lamentable de faire ça non c'est
bon je le faire j'ai pas parler trop
fort là non ça va c'est un match amical
mais quand jean ligne aux cris pas
d'accord je dois me concentrer
mais comme là ça va c'est pas en lice
compris ou pas oui
aux six mois c'est ton portefeuille
vient de trouver par terre à [ __ ] mais
j'ai dû le laisser tomber à merci t'es
sûr que c'est ton portefeuille
ben oui oui c'est ça oui tant mieux
tu vas me laisser ton portefeuille aussi
facilement mais je t'ai vu le sortir de
ta poche
moi j'ai vu des techniques bien pourri
mais alors celle là on est sur un bouton
le valentin ça va merci tu peux à mon
portefeuille je vais vous laisser aux
[ __ ] mon quart ouah qu'est ce qu'il
sait le boulot là ça m'a fait sentir
vieille d'un coup bon on va manger un
truc ça des jets une dalle j'ai envie
d'un truc vraiment bien gras ça te dit
pas bon tu as incompris ou quoi ben je
sais pas on se bat tout le temps on se
lâche des sourires non-stop
donc quoi donc il ya deux options soit
on se plaît beaucoup beaucoup soit
deuxième option battu contre
m'assassiner et moi aussi je compte
assassiné ses styles et ça peut faire un
[ __ ] de scénario ça j'imagine bien
genre et scarlett johansson dans mon
rôle tu vois une nana ouais c'est moi
qui joue mon rôle
toi tu vois moundir dans koh lanta tu
vois tu regardes lui c'est très bien il
ya un truc qui se passe justement deux
mondes se rencontrent
bon je vais pisser du matin
vas-y
votre héros tu es là ouais là je pars en
est avec elle fait mais non il a vu ma
mère l'a tout de suite c'est ça que je
savais que tu pouvais faire tu l'avais
en toi mais oui mon gars tu as pris un à
un hors-jeu et or je regarde il mais il
met du temps à siffler échec j'avoue il
est pas mal mais la coutume en jeu
souvent en ce moment j'essaie d'être un
peu vegan éco-responsable tous avec toi
mais en fait après j'ai encore faim du
coup je vais rien et du coup ça s'annule
complètement bas les couilles
sauf quand même c'est grave ce que tu
m'as dans la vie toi un bon tu trouves
moi parce que je mange des grecs
tu te dis à celle là on n'a même pas été
super entreprenante
je trouve ça cool moi ça se trouve c'est
qu'avec toi peut-être que je crois pas
dans le couple puis comme je t'ai vu je
me suis dit oui peut-être que non je ne
crois pas du tout toi aussi tu sais ce
que tu veux bah ouais tu le dis
peut-être pas exactement mais qd on
regarde mais j'aime bien ça
là tu regrettes ton salades tomates
oignons non non par contre l'union
[Musique]
hier allez raconte la pantoufle avait
pas la jeune mec jade c'est mon plan cul
arrête de croire qu'il va être là à
chaque fois on n'est pas à 100 c'est
sainté clope c'est un bonus
ça va une fois la pêche bref du coup
alors s'explique je sais même pas par où
commencer c'était un truc de dingue
ok bah photo à j'ai juste un vieux c'est
le fric ou photo photo photo [ __ ]
commence pas à bégayer tu me montres
mais non mais non mais russe non mais
toi mais toi avez toi là mais et mais
c'est à ovnis
ça veut dire quoi ça mais qu enfin m
sensei ballon d'or de la chartre aide à
bâle c'est bien aller bien les pas bien
qu'il se passe tu à gérer milla diamond
une actrice de qu cois normal si cher
des actrices mesure de toile bien sûr je
suis sûr de moi mais oui bien sûr je la
connais par coeur
ça veut dire quoi ça ouais ça veut dire
quoi ça je comprends pas ça veut dire
que je veux je me suis je me souviens
très bien d'elle non mais t'as le droit
de regarder du porno ça me dérange pas
mais assume mais j'assume sa reine mais
à quel moment j'ai dit que regarder
films de cul à la touffe echiré d'un
quand tu fais ça là assume ce n'est pas
grave c'est une personnalité connue elle
était dans des reportages réussit très
bien là tu viens de le dire tu parles
chinois assument c'est pas que je
connais plein de personnalité excuse moi
d'avoir de la culture tu piges et de
steevy boulay à col j'avais fabrice déjà
je m'en rappelle qui s'appelle fabrice
[Applaudissements]
elle a tellement elle attend c'est un
mystère ça veut dire qu'elle fait des
trucs d'inceste non steve sisters il n'y
a pas de lien de parenté
ça veut dire que c'est ta soeur par
alliance donc ça va depuis quand le
phare en anglais comme on dit j'ai honte
en anglais comme on dit ça en anglais
blood brest it is titre non mais et ça
va tu te branche jamais ou quoi toi
c'est ici je me branle mais c'est pas
une passion comme toi mais quelle
passion le tu arrêtes de me juger
on voit ce qu'il ya dans la page de voir
s'il ya des trucs on voit pascal en page
2 tu fermes train mais on n'en a même
pas regardé une mais on le regarde pas
du tout en fait ferme reda merci mais en
même temps j'aime à dire c'est un rôle
où tu sors avec ie9 et tu découvres ya
plein de photos d'elle tout le monde
peut voir sa chatte c'est ça comment
j'aimerais pas que ça m'arrive
désormais j'ai pas pensé c'est qu'au
fond je m'en fous comment ça je sais pas
frères c'est le début j'ai pas la juger
tu as a way bah ouais je sais pas après
tu vois je me demande ce qu'elle attend
de moi tu m'as tu as raison de t'en
[ __ ] tu dors pas non j'ai faim à
basile chez des potes
allez on envoie les poils marius on s'en
fout de combien de personnes alitées ou
je sais pas quoi
moi je suis né avec autant de mc call
non mais à peu près et puis ça aucune
incidence sur mes relations maintenant
tu vois c'est que lui sinon on pense à
une vache à lait il avala
rajhi s'en fout de moi 13 ans il kiffe à
mort bon c'est pas la question de toute
manière si tu veux te séparer de
quelqu'un il faut que tu trouves une
raison valable dans ton présent à toi et
pas dans son passé à elle dit comme ça
je veux la revoir
[Musique]
ok on regarde ce qu'on va faire
j'ai préparé la parte et où jade et moi
on va au ciné un bon oui enfin oui comme
ça comme ça on lui laisse la parte pour
lui tout seul comme ça tu as là parce
que pour toi tu vois c'est gentil de
gamera ouais normal du coup ouais et
qu'est ce que j'allais dire ouais soit
tactile c'est une aberration que tu n'es
pas embrasser mec ah ouais bah oui c'est
une actrice de cul c'est ce qu'ils font
dans les films de cul ou quoi bah oui
bon alors voilà inspire toi de ça et le
et la même mentalité faut que tu sois
aussi performant aussi aussi endurant tu
vois si imagine la meuf elle prend moins
de plaisir dans sa vie privée que dans
son travail il ya un truc qui va pas tu
vois tu es sûr de toi
bah oui je suis sûr et mec ça marche
mais conseil ou pas quand je vois ça
marche ça marche
bah voilà aïe dernier truc aussi avant
j'étais moche dans la tête aujourd'hui
je créerai eva mendes c'est ça c'est mon
gars voilà c'est ça tu vois c'est vrai
en vrai avant tt shop mec
crétois le premier soir et on connaît
certains normand je fais pas ça moi
comment ça va quoi quand c'est bon je
sais pas parce qu'ils mois oui c'est
évident fait
voilà bah bienvenue installe toi tu veux
boire quelque chose ouais carrément j'ai
de la vierge ou de la bière moi je
prendrais plutôt une bière sentait santé
c'est marrant carrément l'ambiance et
tous ces films érotiques un peu toi ça
va
non mais si on fait un putsch trop on va
le regarder c'est sa voix grave qu'ait
et tu marques tu n'aimes pas un back up
carrément en fait les mains c'est donc
les fils et les filles de mon collègue
souffre il quand ça me prend quelqu'un
qu'elle choisit bien tassée en octobre
t'es bizarre là c'était un truc à me
dire dire moi parce que là
le sucre est que tu fais là comment ça
je fais quoi as tu me fais mal comme moi
j'écoute aime pas je suis censé alors
que ça fait vingt-quatre heures qu'on
reconnaît bah ouais je sais pas à temps
mais là je comprends pas mais de quoi tu
comprends pas quoique que ma vie
professionnelle et ma vie intime c'est
deux choses très différentes c'est là
que tu comprends pas si tu comprends pas
ça c'est juste que tu es un gros con
quoi donc c'est ça c'est ça
l'explication était un gros con mais il
a attend il a attend
[Musique]
on
[ __ ] ouais j'étais récemment fois par
mois juste à ça va pas expliquer donc
voilà je fais quoi maintenant je suis en
train d'expliquer va maintenant il
m'attend alors ça fait une semaine que
ça s'est fait non non ne marche pas
comme ça y est la solution aller la
liste autonome aux pommes non on
s'embrouille
[Musique]
voix
euh j'ai peut-être trouvé une solution
pour l'histoire avec mila et tout donc
normalement s'il ya moyen que les
frérots en fait se dire un truc des
conseils j'en veux pas maintenant
justement c'est pas des conseils c'est
c'est pour t'aider à tu veut m'aider
oui toi tu va m'aider oui je veux t d
quoi
reda être toi toi même déjà d'accord si
tu veux un conseil commencez par ta voix
de son plan cul c'est par un plan cul
c'est ta copine tu la kiffe d'accord tu
veux te poser avec elle elle attend que
ça fait ça occupe toi de toi
après tout occupera de moi c'est clair
ça c'est clair
bref je vais dire que je sais où emile a
en fait j'ai trouvé l'adresse d'un de
ses tournages donc te l'envoyer sur wat
à oui et puis pour jade
bah ouais t'as raison c'est madoff
c'est tellement ma meuf que ma thèse
donc à que les couples qui peuvent faire
ça bien réagi
[Musique]
oui je peux passer à la crise tout en
sortant du boulot à sa main excuse moi
mais ouais je cherche milan ac temps qui
passait devant moi ça te dérange pas si
j'y vais avant parce que vraiment je
suis chaud la chaux way aux abois alors
monsieur nouveau attention ceci étant le
pape demande de mettre les mains en
l'air
attention ça va partir à poux peut tout
à fait mais que je cherche juste mis là
et j'ai même mis au far-west toi
attention ça peut partir vite et le bel
mais toujours dans les sales coups à ce
que chérif je crois que votre canon est
toujours impeccable
je vois que tu allais y aller fond ce
cobaye sur le cube tout ce sale type
merci chérif baisse les yeux et prendre
de la graine
je trouve ça très inapproprié de vous
voir chez moi je n'étais pas satisfait
de mon audition bière alors je vous
propose d'en voir un petit peu plus
là un bordel c'est qui ce qu'on l'en
marius mais que c'est pas du tout bon
moment si justement ces moments parfaits
ces moments parfaits pour te dire que en
fait je m'en fous tu fasses du porno
voilà et oui tu as raison gt gt un con
même le roi des cons
pour prat avoir traité pour ce que tu es
vraiment à mes yeux c'est à dire là la
fille toute mignonne à qui je pense tous
les jours
et pardon était sûrement bien plus que
ça c'est parce que je veux dire bref ce
que je veux dire c'est que c'est pas à
moi d'imposer ce que je crois que tu es
mais plutôt à toi de me le faire
découvrir
et c'est aussi le moment parfait pour te
prouver que ce que je dis est vrai parce
que parler c'est bien mais agir c'est
mieux qu'ils ne vous arrêtez pas
continuez c'est grave l'union ce que tu
me dire on se croirait dans une comédie
romantique
mais comme on n'est pas dans une comédie
romantique mais comment ça tu peux
enlever sa chemise dès maintenant et
donc en gros elle m'a dit qu'elle
voulait pas se lancer dans une nouvelle
relation
ah ouais ouais
après c'est pas la fin du monde un thème
qu'on se revoie et tous de chaque chose
en son temps tu vois c'est moi aussi
j'ai abusé je fais une grande
déclaration avec des bisous à
l'américaine tout
j'avoue tu t'es donné là dessus de ouf
j'avais écrit un texte
ben voilà trop too much mais c'est qu'en
vrai je la comprends parce que moi même
je sais pas vraiment ce que je vais en
bresse est tellement chaude et en coupe
c'est ça le truc mais alors je suis
désolée pour ce que ce que j'ai dit sur
jeunes non tranquille tu m'as fait
ouvrir les yeux et on se voit demain
soir on va s'expliquer à retraite demain
soir on va se capter là on va essayer
d'éclaircir le truc c'est pas ce que ça
va donner mais tu vois ça tu le tcc
ouais non vraiment je t'en veux plus
voilà je voulais te dire maintenant je
peux plus t'en vouloir
pourquoi parce que tu t'es fait elle
aussi on sait que les tests la vérité
d'accord d'effluents allons on va
d'habitude ah la la
marius
gère des accords
imagine imagine tu serais posé
lesquelles mon avant la présentation
d'art on est en 2010 je vous ai déjà vu
les acclamait vous me dites calcul chéri
à l'intérieur n'ont pas
[Musique]